first shot boobs second side blood their
shot violence there's an explosion ha
come see the movie hi I'm type a locker
with reason TV today I'll be sitting
down with filmmaker marcus dunstan
dunstan and his partner Patrick Melton
wrote the last three saw films including
saw 6 which hits theaters October 23rd
this summer Dunston made his directorial
debut with the collector which he and
melton also co-wrote so let's dive into
saw six went the viewers appetite a bit
what can they expect alright well what
I'm truly excited about what Sussex is
that for the first time in a series
that's you know been around consistently
every year on halloween weekend they
elected to tackle a timely issue it's an
issue you can turn on your TV and hear
about it every night we've seen people
fight about it die for it shed blood for
it and now this movie was a genuine
wonderful opportunity to say oh you
think it's bad now what if it was put
through the saw machine and you'll
really see this issue come to life and
probably the most ferocious way possible
while hopefully taking a nice bit of joy
and seeing what happens and that issue
is well that's that's that's gonna be
that [ __ ] is nicely yeah I did I I
literally had a phone call with the with
the Lions Gate pressing am get them
going on I might ask a few questions no
plot details we know where you live and
they do and then they drop their voice
and you actually hear that good you must
have run into censorship issues at some
point with those cell phones the line of
what is too far changes from year to
year and it's you know I had the good
fortune to witness it a few times and
witness the techniques on how to avoid
that I mean you can you can run in and
you'll screen these films in front of a
room of people that are going to hold
that line and determine where it is that
day should they be offended they can
request that a whole heck of a lot of
your show goes away even things like
either violence against animals is a
very taboo I'm thinking of the collector
which is your directorial debut and the
poor little kitty who gets peeled off
yes so in one case thief ones into a
room and discovers that the floor has
been covered with an adhesive napalm
substance but oh
the family cat stuck in it too and it's
creating a very lifelike version of an
alarm going instead of a beep beep beep
it's a cat with the tear melting up guy
freaking out so I thought well if we
really push this just right in weight
and we do it we can we can have
something that will absolutely keep
their attention be a genuine a real
original moment I think by this point
we've seen every you know tool in the
garden shed used on some teenager maybe
this one can can be owned by this very
movie this is something that only will
you'll only see in that and yes it did
involve destroying a lovely lovely film
cat the actual cat of course all three
of them that played that part we're just
fine yeah that was great so I thought
you were chilled bad cats we're only bet
well this cat was an obvious racist okay
no not even a GED just junk well you
must have been gratified when we saw the
reviews you got great reviews and and I
want to focus first on the the new media
aspect of that because this this outlet
ain't it cool news that nobody had ever
heard of you know not so long ago
figured in very prominently in the
promotion of the collector you talk
about that oh my goodness well you know
you get the you get the right good
review for example we I think in equal
news was a lightning bolt of good
fortune for the collector because it
raised awareness of the film throughout
town then all of a sudden once it became
a point of awareness in Los Angeles well
then well we didn't have to create an
event a spectacle out of the time it
would be shown we would be receiving
people that were already chomping at the
bit to see it and providing the best
time for them says the movie had already
had its you know introduction to them so
to speak then the day before it comes
out I believe when a wonderful review
from variety pops up holy cow it's not
just the blogosphere that's saying this
is okay now variety the one that's also
praising the latest drama the latest you
know fine-tuned indie something like
that it raises this profile in it it
also it gives it I think a sheen that is
very helpful we went from what we've
been a modestly sized premiere in a very
excellent gothic location a cemetery to
way we've got some good where
let's have a proper premiere we're going
to the mann's chinese we're doing this
mom dad everybody's coming and here's
the after party right across the street
at this fancy poolside hotel and it was
it was you know intoxicating on any
number of levels to to see that in
Patrick and I who had had this idea for
years and years and years and cultivated
that became the collector we were able
to stand introduced it in front of an
audience of our friends family and the
people that sweat and blood to make it
happen and I think one is absolutely
lucky to get one of those feelings in a
lifetime you mentioned the variety
review very strong it does it uses the
term torture porn people talk when they
talk about saath films when they talk
about the hostile films for example that
you hear the term torture porn Gordon
ography Eli Roth I think doesn't much
like them but again the variety review
used it in a positive context how do you
respond to those terms well I think one
is you know it's a it's a classification
that creates more of a sub-genre than
any reaction of like bio hostility for
me it's like it it's okay if this does
feature such an act of intentional
maiming and whatnot then you know what
sure I if I was diff I was to take a
step bags like yeah this was the one
where we've got three or four scenes
that depict it but there's also five
scenes that are about the suspense movie
and there's a whole half an hour
thriller however what strikes the
biggest cord is sure it is going to be
that the most intense vicious moment of
violence and if that is surrounded and
immersed in the world of torture yes I'm
by offering it out there I'm asking for
that label if we can just touch on the
censorship thing a bit more there are
certain things that in a TV trailer you
can show and you cannot show yes however
then you go online online all of a
sudden you can create or you can even in
theaters create red-band trailers that
you can log in the age and your content
once content is just you know easily
it's just less restricted it can be it
can hit it can be read it can be it can
have nudity but only then
in certain degrees you can't go all the
way over the top but you you can at
least have a bit more freedom and I
think not a lot of films you know not a
lot of people get to see a lot of films
a year if they're you know once they
clear high school college they're
probably locked into a job that makes
them maybe they want to do something
else with their night and catch one
movie week or something you've got five
trailers before that movie maybe if
you're you know early enough to see them
however online every Tuesday you can go
to apple trailers calm and see them all
and pick which movie you might want to
see and so they're Wow now all of a
sudden your content can be exactly what
you wanted to deliver if you're willing
to have an age gate do a red band be
submitted for that way and that's that's
been refreshing that's that's that's
nice we had a young man named David
carlac make a blood band trailer when
our red band trailer for the collector
was deemed not red enough by the fans
from the an equal news site we fought
back with a blood band trailer which was
like here it is first shot boobs second
side blood there's shot violence there's
an explosion ha come see the movie and
it seemed to work out okay so I think
you know the world wide web is its thank
goodness it's a wild frontier
[Music]